40 percent of people aren't pitching up
for their booster jobs
well that's not everywhere that's in
certain uh places certain uh centers
um and so
what we're emphasizing today is the
importance of people getting that
booster jab and
if you've booked in for the job if you
can't
get there because perhaps you've had a
positive result or whatever that's
understandable but then please try to
cancel the appointment if you can so it
can be offered to somebody else
more broadly
what worries me is a certain complacency
at the moment about the situation that
we're in and
i don't blame the public because we're
hearing mixed messages we we read
headlines about omicron not being
so severe or that the peak has passed in
south africa or whatever but we need to
recognize that yesterday we saw the
biggest increase in the number of people
in hospital in a day that we've seen
since december
2020 that yesterday the health service
had to announce the creation of surge
capacity building
new capacity in hospitals because of the
fact that hospitals may be overwhelmed
by the number of people
we are still at an early stage uh in the
wave of this new variant it's only a
month since we first heard of omicron so
it just it's really important that we
don't get complacent whether it's public
policy or the individual choices that we
make uh we are in a very dangerous and
difficult situation and we need to
behave in the right ways and getting the
booster is the absolute number one thing
so so you really if you if you can go
out and have that booster job if you
booked in for it then do turn up it's
really important
but more broadly as a society we've got
to recognize the difficult and dangerous
situation that we're in
um do you have any idea if you look at
the people who are in hospital
and who are in icu um in icu beds do you
have any idea of the number of people
who are unvaccinated how many
vaccinations they've had whether they've
had their booster or not can you give us
an idea of that
i think it's pretty clear that the
majority of people in icu are not fully
vaccinated even though a minority of the
population
so that is to say most people who are
getting very sick are not vaccinated
even though most of us are vaccinated so
your risk of becoming ill and becoming
serious ill is massively greater if
you're not
vaccinated it is still not too late one
of the good bits of news we've seen over
the last few weeks is that the booster
campaign seems to encourage some people
who hadn't come forward for their first
or their second vaccine to do so
but we need to keep that
pressure on we need to be really strong
about that message and
you know nhs staff as much as anybody
else like to have a good time want to go
out want to return to normal but we are
in a very difficult and dangerous
position right now in our health service
and we need to stay focused on doing
whatever we can to minimize unnecessary
demands on our health service
okay let's just talk through um the
actual practicalities of the booster if
you've had a message that says you need
to get your booster jab but you can't do
a walk-in
what is the situation there can everyone
go into a walk-in center now
so
it's easy to book and um also many
centers do have walk-in capacity so
you know i i would say try and book but
also if there is um a center near you
then go to that center because it may
well be sadly partly because of the
number of people who are counselling
that you can get
um your booster straight away generally
speaking if you want to get your booster
it is easy to do so um the problem that
we've got to an extent is people booking
in and they're not turning up which
means that we don't there's there's
additional capacity that's not being
used
okay so what happens if let's say you've
booked your booster for monday you test
positive today
what what do you do about that booking
if you can cancel it you should try to
cancel it because clearly if you are
within that with if you're within the
isolation period
then you
shouldn't be going out and mixing up
with other people so that may be one of
the reasons for the number of people who
are not turning up and i know that
sometimes the systems don't make it as
easy to cancel as they should do but i
would say to people make every effort
you can to cancel that appointment and
then to make another one
okay and if you happen to walk past a
center and they say we're doing walk-ins
here but you've got that text that said
you can't do walk-ins can you just go in
anyway
if as far as i understand it if you are
not positive you've had a negative test
and
you're near a center you can walk in and
get that booster jab we'll find out the
booster jab is available the only thing
that should stop you from getting the
booster jab is the period of time since
your last jab and
whether you yourself are infected but as
long as you've had a clear lateral flow
test and there's a if there's a center
available to you you should walk in if
you can
is there a period between actually
having covert 19 and the time that you
can have that booster
uh i think the the specifics are on
the the the gap between uh having had
the infection and getting the booster uh
i to be honest i'm not absolutely clear
the the rules you know
on that i would encourage people to go
to the nhs website and check that out
okay have a look at that but basically
get boosted
look
that is the most important thing that we
can do but we must
and you know that's the thing we should
emphasize what the government is
emphasizing but i would also say to
people you know on new year's eve
please do be careful
uh in the things that you do try to
avoid getting this virus or passing it
on try to avoid
risky behavior bear in mind tonight when
you're celebrating new year's eve that
there will be hospitals across this
country and community settings mental
health settings where nhs workers will
be working through the night under very
difficult circumstances with the number
of people who are sick rising very
steeply so please bear that in mind when
you think about your activities over the
next few days
in an ideal situation let's say you're
going over to dinner at someone's house
you should all have a lateral flow test
before you go shouldn't you how should
that be about half an hour before you go
or what what do you think would be an
ideal situation so you need to have a
lateral flow test
i would encourage people to be having
lateral flow tests
um
as often as they can you should have the
test at least half an hour before you go
out because it can take half an hour for
the result
uh to show up
and even if you do have a clear test
result i would encourage people not to
meet in large groups i would encourage
you to ventilate the room
any room that you're in what what's
concerning me right now is that a lot of
people are going to go out to pubs and
clubs
tonight these are noisy venues they're
often not that well ventilated people
tend to shout because there's music
going on all of those things are things
which spread this virus so you know
that's what the government has decided
we've not got extra restrictions but you
know but do be careful and i'd also
encourage those venues that
they are required to make sure that
people um have had are testing
themselves but it is important to make
sure that that is taking place i know
it's difficult you know people are
outside a club they want to get in
to make sure that people have really can
demonstrate that they've got a negative
test but that is going to be important
because those kind of venues with people
packed in together loud music
we know and we've known this for years
and with omicron it's particularly the
case you only need to have a small
number of people there who
do have the virus and that can spread
throughout that group very very quickly
this issue of lateral flow tests and pcr
tests and the uh the fact that we just
don't have enough here in england do you
think that healthcare staff should be
prioritized
uh i think absolutely right now because
the twin pressures that we have on the
health service beyond all the ordinary
pressures that we have in winter
are this rising number of patients who
have a covid diagnosis so that went up
by over a thousand yesterday which is
the the biggest increase we've seen
for over a year and on the other hand
the number of nhs staff themselves
who are sick or having to uh isolate
so yes we need to get those tests into
the hands of nhs workers because
for the nhs staff like for other people
if you can do the test you can have two
days of clear test it does mean you can
go back to work that little bit earlier
so yes we should be prioritizing nhs
staff and care staff as well i would say
because another issue for hospitals is
is getting people out of hospital who
are able to
and if i might say it is important this
is not just this issue about hospitals
there are many patients now out in the
community who've got covid colleagues in
primary care who are responsible for
delivering the booster program are also
having to keep an eye on a growing
number of people in their homes who are
managing kovid and keeping an eye on
them so we've got rising numbers of
coveted incidents in in uh people being
absorbed by primary care in the
community as well
okay matthew teller chief executive of
the nhs confederation none of this is
easy is it thank you so much for talking
to us and i hope you do have a happy new
year albeit a cautious one thank you
thank you so much